What happens when ice
bears start losingtheir ice?
They get stuck on land and they get hungry.
When polar bears can't
find goodfood to eat,
they'll fill up on junk food.
And for polar bears, junk
food is human food.
This is a rising safety concern for humans.
After working and livingoff and on
with polar bears for over 12 years,
I know coexisting with them
can be a challenge,
and it will only get more challenging
as climate change forces our
species to increasingly overlap.
Polar Bears International is
working on innovative technologies
thatcould help provide longer lead times
between when polar bears and people meet
or preventthem from meeting altogether.
Just one example,
GPS tracking.
It can tell us where, when and
whypolar bears move.
It's critical data.
The number one most important
coexistence tool we have
isour willingness to cut carbon emissions
and stop trapping so much
heat in our atmosphere.
The faster we switch to cleaner energies,
the better we can protect future
generations of polar bears and people.